stored in this Belgian lab is a growing
health threat that's too small for the
naked eye to see drug resistant microbes
normally my sister's antibiotic Oh Tom
if a portal a bacterial
McCumber prevail voila oh god the sick
cows Oh terrific
no God if you tested it excessive
Claremont invective unity resistant
doctors are increasingly faced with
untreatable bacterial infections because
the antibiotics simply no longer work
accorded a concern I assumed antibiotic
I believe as important and at the
present plus the bacteria so Jose Santos
antibiotic a don't succumb click before
prison charged and pursue a victim
vector humidity resistant the abuse of
antibiotics isn't only limited to humans
resistant bacteria are also transferred
from animals to humans through both
direct contact and the food chain
the problem has set off alarm bells
around the world 700,000 deaths a year
are linked to drug resistant infections
in the EU alone four million people a
year contract infections in hospitals
breeding ground for bacteria
Parliament is urging the Commissioner
Member States to implement better
measures to combat the problem from
increasing awareness about the proper
prescriptions and use of antibiotics to
improved hygiene and security it's
little steps that can really make the
big difference like washing your hands
in the hospital then we have a lot of
people who take antibiotics even if they
don't work at the moment because they
have a viral infection so it's the
prudent use it's the correct use in
addition to funding EU research on the
matter Parliament calls for more
investments in new models private
partners and alternatives